hello grammarians continuing our journey
through the world of frequently confused
words i'd like to begin with complement
with two e's and complement with an i
and an e
how the heck do we keep these separate
well first let's get some definitions
complement with two e's
c-o-m-p-l-e-m-e-n-t
is a verb
and it means to match pair or work well
with something
as in that hat complements your suit
melvin
there's our guy melvin
there's this very fine hat in the same
color as his suit so it matches or pairs
or works well with something these are
the same colors so they look nice
together
maybe a little matchy-matchy
and give him some
gold epaulettes
shake it up a little bit melvin there
you go
complement with an i c-o-m-p-l-i-m-e-n-t
is a verb that means to praise
or noun that just means
praise
so complement with an e is the verb of
actually matching but when we point it
out um and we say fat hat complements
your suit melvin and we say that looks
pretty good melvin that in itself is a
compliment
so this sentence
is a compliment so melvin would say in
response thank you for the
so i can see how this is confusing so
when two things go together well like
visually or
sonically or however you say they
complement one another when two people
work well as a team you can say their
skills complement one another
and if you point that out in a way that
is praiseworthy if you say ah melvin
that is a dope ensemble you are rocking
today that is a compliment with an eye
so you are praising it this one is a
classic so we've got
desert over here and dessert
over here
so these words look a little similar but
they are pronounced different languages
which is to our benefit so these are
both nouns so desert with a za sound za
is dry sandy land
so for example this is a depiction of
the sonoran desert in arizona and mexico
right so this is a saguaro cactus
that there's a barrel cactus
that's a palo verde
there's a little kit fox
so when you see desert with one s as
opposed to dessert with two s's what i
want you to imagine is water
a long
[Music]
flowing
river made of s's and that when you're
in a desert
there just isn't as much there isn't as
much water so 1s means less water
means cacti
and little kid foxes and gila monsters
dessert with two s's
is like an ice cream sundae
we got some vanilla ice cream we got
some strawberry ice cream
and then this black ice cream is
licorice ice cream which is actually
delicious and i encourage you to try it
and then this if you couldn't tell is a
banana so what is a dessert so a dessert
is a noun and it is a sweet food eaten
after a meal
certainly doesn't have to be this banana
split this ice cream sundae could be
anything sweet so cookies cake chocolate
the sorts of things that you would not
find in a desert so keeping these two
words straight desert and dessert is
really one of abundance
when there's two s's it means uh
times are good we're doing so well we
can have
ice cream
if you're missing that second s it means
things are a little lean
there's not a lot of water there's a lot
of cacti
and rattlesnakes
don't get me wrong i've had some
excellent desserts with two s's in
desert places
there happens to be a very fine ice
cream parlor in scottsdale arizona but
what i'm trying to say is that in the
land form that we call a desert with one
s you are unlikely to find
an ice cream sundae just sitting out
you can learn anything dave it out